what makes a great story oh my god what
makes a great story wow that's a good
question I have a friend who's like a
real writer writer and he always gets on
me because I don't I don't care a lot
about plot and I think there's probably
two camps maybe there's people who care
about character and there are people who
care about plot and I don't know if
that's that's part of it I think like I
think it just has to be there has to be
a reality to it I think that that for me
rather than like you know it's funny
because I was just talking to my
students about this there has been this
thing in recent years and it's not new
but I could say in the last five to
seven years where the value of a story
is related directly to whether or not
the audience can cannot anticipate what
the ending is going to be in other words
the twist has become so suddenly the
gold standard of what a great story in
other words I didn't see it coming
that's what makes it a great story you
got me you know that's what makes it a
great story and I feel like that's kind
of cheap you know
in a way so I feel like it has to be
character based that the characters have
to be real first and I'll almost forgive
a plot that is not so clever if the
characters are strong and real that's
that's to me that's my standard at least
now that's right so if the characters
seem too much like they're acting
quote-unquote you know even though it
must it's a great story and you didn't
see the ending coming to you that
doesn't I think I think characters that
serve the plot are less interesting the
characters and characters that motivate
plot like there's there's a certain
philosophy I'm sure I'm certain because
you guys have interviewed so many
writers but you know I think whether
it's easy for me or it's just something
I happen to subscribe to but I feel like
if you can create a character first that
and create a character in a certain
number of situations and not necessarily
and not I've certainly outlined the
entire movie although it depends on the
movie but if you have a full character
that's real that you've created and then
you put something in front of them in a
way they will begin to write the movie
because you know how they're going to
react to whatever you put in front of
because they're now these dimensional
characters as opposed to let's have this
happen let's have this happen let's add
this happen and we'll just make sure
that they do these things that I've you
know preordained and I think that's what
creates a feeling of artifice or you've
seen it all before or boring I think and
and so to me if you create a real
character then whatever happens as a
result of those characters interacting
is bound to be more interesting than
somebody something that's just been
constructed like I I was attached to a
big studio movie not too long ago and
the script was greenlit and everybody
loved it and I was reading this thing
and I was like I don't understand this
like and it's is not a complicated movie
this was like a movie with dinosaurs and
fighting and all that I'm reading this
thing and I'm like why is this guy dude
why is this guy doing this and I went to
the writer and I said you know what this
doesn't really make much sense you you
you in the in the in the first act you
talked about how this guy was scared of
heights there was a whole dialogue about
he was scared of climbing the mountain
and then later he's like on a tightrope
fighting a terror attack or like wow wow
what's going on with that and he goes I
just thought that tiger thing was cool
and I was like yeah but it doesn't make
any sense you understand it's like you
know you set up this guy so there's got
to be you can't just put stuff in
because it's cool I mean people do it
all the time but as a director of this
thing uh I was looking at it like well
how am I supposed to direct this with
any kind of confidence or Authority if I
don't believe this thing and so I think
there's a lot of writing that's just
like well let's be cool this happens and
let's have this happen but that'd be
cool too and you have this pileup of
cool but that doesn't have any
resonance because it's not based in any
kind of reality or at least any kind of
consistency or something like that I
don't know if that makes sense but
that's that's something it does so
characters quote arc didn't didn't cross
over to the tightrope scene like was
there did the character go to a
fear-based weekend why don't they just
have him acknowledge the fact that you
know when it got to the tightrope scene
that he was still scared but was
overcoming you know what it means like
but it's almost this
negligence not even negligence is almost
like apathy like who cares whether it's
consistent who cares whether it makes
sense as long as it's cool and I think
the coolest movies that have the coolest
still are weighted or or or rooted
in some sort of reality that they the
writer has believed and has maintained
as opposed to just an assembly of things
that that that just happened to be
exciting but don't really either trace
back to something or connect or make
sense for the character that's really
what it is does it make sense for the
character would he do that you know so
like the example I always give my
students is that like if we're walking
along the street and all of a sudden a
mugger jumps out with a gun and grabs
your bag and runs and that's all we have
in terms of like that's the only idea we
could come up with in terms of plot the
next scene is if we know who we are we
know what's gonna happen like if you for
me like if the mugger pulls out a gun
I'll probably you know fall down on the
ground and cry and weep and hope for it
to be over on the other hand if I had
created like if you're you're a former
cop or you were in the war or any ceil
or whatever you know or somebody who's
like been you know mugged a couple of
times and now carries like brass
knuckles and mace whatever the deal of
whatever you set up what happens as a
result of that mugger pulling the gun
and grabbing thing and running it's
either becomes a chase or it becomes us
going to a bar and crying together or
whatever it is but you least you know or
it's a fight or whatever it is but you
don't have to have the pressure of okay
and now I've got to come up with the
next thing now I've got to come up with
the next thing because if the character
is built then it will dictate to you in
a way what what will happen which is
actually less pressure on the writer
because now you don't have the burden of
having to make up every goddamn thing
the characters are in fact writing the
movie to a certain extent they talk
about having that dialogue test where
someone's just reading a character and
then people need to try to figure out
who's speaking and if your character is
authentic enough we should all know to
be able to identify yeah
in fact there are things like for
example there were since situations
where when my writing partner Jim and I
were first coming up with one of our
films lucu Karachi way back in the 90s
and one of the first images that came to
mind was this idea of a man in a
wheelchair in almost this True Grit sort
of scenario where he was like rolling
into this town like guns blazing in a
wheelchair that was the first idea in
Mexico we didn't even know how how it
got there but that was the image and I
was like holy that's amazing we got
to make this move we got to write this
we got to figure out and the irony was
by the time we had created really this
character and this scenario of this
writer who goes down to Mexico who was
really not a tough guy at all and
everything goes wrong by the time we got
to this finale which was the seed of the
whole thing as much as we wanted this
badass thing to happen it didn't make
any sense anymore it was like too big it
was it was out of character it didn't
make sense that this would happen he
wouldn't do this and we were kept trying
to like force ourselves into writing
this thing and was like no it's not
going to be that because that's not
that's not true to the thing that we
actually wrote so I mean it depends on
your philosophy a studio is not going to
give a about that it's gonna say
put the wheelchair thing in
because that's awesome but a but a
writer with any kind of conscience is
gonna be like either go no that doesn't
work or they're gonna have to really
find a way to justify I always heard
that that that was Hitchcock's thing
that he would come up with a series of
set pieces sorry no that's okay I always
heard that Hitchcock basically came up
with a sequence of really cool set
pieces like I want to chase across the
faces of Mount Rushmore but I don't know
how it happens and then he would lay it
on the writer to somehow get you know I
want a Mount Rushmore thing I want a
crop-dusting thing that'll be awesome I
want to stage those and shoot those
things I don't know how the hell it
happens and now it's your job you know
mr. and mrs. Ryder to figure out how to
make it make sense of course he had the
luxury of being able to do that the
writers still had to figure it out
though the writers still and when you
watch North by Northwest Union you look
at it and you're like wow that's a lot
of like
effort to kill this guy really they're
gonna they're gonna bring them out to a
cornfield and they're gonna try to kill
him with a crop duster why doesn't
somebody just pop out and shoot the guy
in that in that easier the shouldn't
just be a sniper in the clockwise are a
crop duster well it's because Hitchcock
came up with this awesome idea and
they're and the writer is just basically
going okay well if I maneuver this
enough maybe no one will notice that
it's insane so I don't know I guess I
guess it really does depend on the
philosophy of the writer her the
filmmaker
you